welcome back to a20
in the previous section we have seen the
relativistic doppler effect and now we
want to study how light
in this case a monochromatic plane wave
transforms under lauren's transformation
in other words um you know we have for
example a a distant star emitting
uh light at a specific frequency the
question now is how do we observe this
light when the light then the star is
traveling away from us or towards us
so
here you see
our monochromatic wave plane wave
we have an amplitude a and then just a
simple cosine which is a function of x y
and t time
this is the solution of the wave
equation and we have already seen this
as part of the psets
but also discussed in class
so the wave is characterized by
so-called wave numbers in x-direction
and y-direction
um the squared sum the square root of
the square sum is the so-called wave
number
the frequency omega is equal to 2 pi f
where f is the frequency and omega is
the angular frequency and if you divide
the angular frequency by the wave number
we get the speed of light similarly we
can multiply the frequency in the
wavelength
okay so as the first activity i will ask
you to know
see that
how does this solution how does this
specific wave
transform under lauren's transformation
as a reminder we have seen that the
equation which governs
how
this light propagates is invariant under
the lawrence transformation but now we
want to investigate what happens to the
wave itself
okay
so we have to you know investigate
this specific solution
and
launch transform x and t
and i'll just do this here
in this equation so you see that now we
have
as part of the cosine
kx gamma x prime
plus beta c t prime
plus no no change in y direction as we
uh look at a lens transformation x
direction and then we have the
transformation of the time axis okay
so now this looks very cumbersome or
complicated but we can try to
re-find the very same calculation of the
wave as we had before how does now the
transformed wave number look like how
does the frequency look like after
learn's transformation
and so we want to identify the
individual terms
kx prime or we label kx prime as the
parameter
we find here in in the solution in this
lawrence transformed solution and we do
the same for omega prime
and you find the solution here
so now there's this angle cosine i
i defined at the angle with respect to
the line of motion
omega prime is now the baseline
frequency and omega the one which is
detected that's just a matter of
changing the direction of of beta with a
plus and minus sign but if you use that
definition you can now discuss the
result
so as part of the discussion we can
look at the specific case where the wave
is moving towards us
okay so
zeta is equal to zero and beta is
positive
in this case omega is larger than omega
prime
omega prime
and so the
frequency is going to be higher so the
detected frequency is going to be higher
blue shifted so if we have a situation
that the star is moving towards us and
emitting light the light is detected by
us maybe by our eyes or by a telescope
that light is going to be blue shifted
it's going to go to higher frequencies
the opposite scenario is where theta is
equal to 180 degrees
or
n beta equal to
greater than zero or the other way
around we could have defined this also
as theta equals zero and beta negative
in this case
in this case
um omega is smaller than omega prime so
the frequency is lower meaning that the
light we observe is well shifted
and therefore this this term redshift is
a measure of whether or not the source
of light is moving towards us or away
from us and the larger the redshift the
higher the velocity is of this object
moving away from us
so we can define this red shift as the
relative change in frequency omega prime
minus omega over omega or we can define
one plus z one plus the redshift is
omega prime over omega which is square
root of 1 plus beta over 1 minus beta
all right
so if we now observe the stars in our
galaxy and we can do this for example by
its specific spectral form the specific
spectral lines lines of specific
frequency which we can observe from
stars
as they are in certain distance from
from our solar system and if we do this
we basically see all stars being wet
shifted meaning all stars are actually
moving away from us which is a measure
of the fact that the universe is
expanding
you